haha the Joe Rogan experience you know I
talked to Ari Shaffir yes alright
excellent Ari
he's quarantined himself in Maryland for
two weeks he's just he's run out of
edibles and he's not smoking it because
he thinks it makes you vulnerable to
Corona so he's living like a he's doing
yoga living a clean life
good for him yeah so he's gonna do that
for two weeks and he's gonna move in
with his folks right yeah yeah I think
he just decided to play it that way
smart move coming from New York because
that's where Michael yo got it that's
where there's the most cases in the
country right now meanwhile they say
more cases in the United States and more
deaths in United States than China and I
don't buy that I was reading that this
scientist was saying that is literally
almost impossible you're dealing with a
country that has three times the amount
of people and it broke out there so
there's three times the amount of people
who broke out there it's been going on
far longer that it's been going on here
and they're saying there's less deaths
in China than there are here and less
people infected yeah yeah
China conceal'd extent of virus outbreak
US intelligence says that's from
Bloomberg yeah that should say duh yeah
yeah of course they did now when they
shoot you for reporting the truth
yeah dude there's 21 million people
missing from their cell phone database
they're really 21 million that doesn't
mean it doesn't mean that 21 million
people are dead from the virus but let's
just say it's only 10% of those people
yeah let's say it's that that's 2
million people done all right let's say
it's 10% of that come on man 200,000
people did how many people how many
people really died is it really only
30,000 or whatever they said how many
did they say died it's not that many
well they've also loosened up their
restrictions now so if it if it didn't
get if it didn't get that bad it will
get that bad because it'll have a
boomerang now that they open it up again
well they tried to open up movie
theaters and they immediately closed
them back down again well here people as
soon as they relax things
the divorce rate went up
shot through the roof in China 3000
deaths get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah right eighty-one thousand cases we
have way more cases only three thousand
deaths we have more deaths come on yeah
they listen you're dealing with a
military dictatorship they get to decide
what information gets revealed and
anything that would show them to have
made a mistake or to be liable or to be
negligent or incompetent is going to be
suppressed
well what's North Korea saying it's good
question I haven't heard a peep out of
North Korea South Korea apparently got
on it very quickly they were saying that
Germany has the best results they have a
very very low mortality rate and they
don't know if it's because the
stringency of their system the health of
the people whether it's a combination of
things they have apparently are very
good health care system but it makes
sounds like the thing about the way
Germans make cars you know yeah there's
so well engineered it's so well thought
out North Korea claims no coronavirus
cases your [ __ ] credit card number
and kim jeong-hoon just shot an 11 again
last week in golf yeah
oh to see how crazy golf scores yeah
does he really he claims that he got a
hole-in-one on every hole there's
something crazy
we're gonna like a 27 out of 18 hole
really really yeah what does that say
like Tiger Woods world-class no no Tiger
Woods will shoot a great round of 63 so
this guy says like 17 I forget what it
is but it's like it entails several
holes in one in one round that must be
fun though to be able to just tell
people every day like all right print
this
I [ __ ] nine women last night they were
all tens they said he got a 34 a 38
underpart
34 by the way Lil Duval who's the best
follow on Instagram right now he's all
days been posting about the the corona
virus and funny memes and shed but he
had one with the
the king of Thailand the king of
Thailand is sequestered in his palace
with his 18 girlfriends is that
sequestered yes it is it's just him and
them and just a long bone session how
many does he have like you feeling any
better no I need a little more time the
king of Thailand had a girl that was
like his number one girl here this came
to oh excuse me 20 girlfriend Wow
he's in a luxury hotel with 20
girlfriends so he's got em all in rooms
they can't go anywhere and stay put that
with all his medals are for yes for
[ __ ] he won the [ __ ] Olympics
every year he stands on the podium
holding his dick that is so crazy
there's just different styles of life
but uh I think Lil Duval wrote
aspirations yes the same guy no [ __ ] not
only did he took away her military
position because she was disrespectful
to the Queen Wow yeah he made her bow
down friend everybody you watch the
video click it says watch the video you
should watch the video as he made her
his official concubine and ceremony
attended by his wife so that was when he
made his official concubine that was one
video but there's another video where he
took away the title which hasn't been
bestowed upon someone in a long time
apparently he took it away cuz she she
slipped of the tongue look at this
official concubine look at bowing down
oh she gives the conquer my crown just
imagine living like that
imagine the whole world he gives her
something to eat what is she doing she
putting in her hair like a leaf of flour
to put behind her ear yeah there's like
rules stuff you have to do meanwhile the
wives like mm-hmm
this [ __ ] focuses [ __ ] doing okay they
all have to be on their knees in front
of him I guess lots of different ways to
go all right
huh yeah Wow maybe he's got the best
time of this coronavirus thailand's
playboy King was taken over a luxury
German hotel to isolate from the
coronavirus along with a harem of 20
women salute 67 keep on rockin in the
free world sir 20 women hmm it seems
like a lot I guess it's you know maybe
you know something we don't know yeah he
whatever his diet is I need it well
maybe it's just like he knows it's gonna
take a long time yeah maybe they get two
world leaders and they go look we got a
couple of years it was not clear if his
fourth wife former flight attendant was
even with him the baller move would be
to like wait four days and then send
four more women right just to blow
people's minds yeah with golden
underwear on you just put pose at the
balcony every down then stand out of the
balcony overlooking the city with a
glass of champagne with golden underwear
just look around and you go right back
in send in some more [ __ ]
[Applause]